il revendique sa nouvelle liberté au
sein de l'ump dont la survie politique
d'ailleurs n'est pas assuré xavier
bertrand est l'invité de preuve par
trois bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
et avec guillaume daudin de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire avec
dailymotion comme chaque semaine et bien
sûr perrine tarneaud de public sénat
remet alors que le ministre de la
défense jean yves le drian vanter le
succès de l'opération en serval contre
les islamistes au mali une opération
parfaitement réussie a ajouté le chef de
l'état françois hollande un soldat
français un légionnaire a donc trouvé la
mort dans un attentat suicide le premier
du genre hélas sc la preuve selon vous
xavier bertrand qu'on ne peut jamais
crier victoire contre le terrorisme
toujours se garder les paroles
définitives parce qu'on n'est jamais à
l'abri d'un drame comme celui qui est
qui est survenu maintenant il n'empêche
que je continue à porter mon soutien à
cette opération parce que je pense que
la france a raison de s'impliquer en
afrique pour lutter contre le terrorisme
le combat contre le terrorisme se joue
aussi au delà de nos frontières et
notamment en afrique donc vous approuvez
également l'extension de cette mission
de défense française sur l'ensemble du
sel avec le déplacement du chef de
l'état à la fin de la semaine en afrique
oui je l'approuvent je les dis c'est la
question du combat contre le terrorisme
et je pense qu'en plus la france a une
vocation particulière à s'investir en
afrique si ce ne sont pas les français
qui le font qu'il fera personne personne
bien évidemment je souhaiterais que nous
ne soyons pas seul je souhaiterais qu'il
y ait un relais européen mais ça pose la
question de la diplomatie européenne ça
pose la question également de la défense
au niveau européen mais en attendant je
pense que la france a tout à fait
vocation à jouer ce rôle en matière de
sécurité ce n'est pas seulement
d'ailleurs pour protéger les intérêts
français mais c'est aussi pour protéger
l'euro ça c'est un reproche qui est
adressée vous dit c'est pas seulement
mais c'est un reproche qui est fait
aussi on l'entend mais ceux qui nous
font des reproches bien souvent sont
absents et serait aussi les premiers à
déplorer qu'on n'est pas porter la lutte
contre le terrorisme
là bas aussi alors voilà un premier un
consensus on verra dans l'émission s'il
y en a d'autres xavier bertrand tous les
cas le 14 juillet a été l'occasion pour
l'armée de présenter ses forces - ses
faiblesses que vous dénoncez pourtant
les plus hauts gradés j'ai vu se dit
satisfait désormais de la loi de
programmation militaire qui préserve a
semble-t-il les moyens fondamentaux est
ce que votre affirmation d'un plan caché
visant la défense est encore d'actualité
selon vous ai bien fait de dénoncer ce
plan caché parce qu'il existait il a été
confirmé à demi mot par le premier
ministre il a été confirmé par le
ministre de la défense qui était en
prise à leo'o qovu de bercy du ministère
des comptes qui voulait à tout prix
revenir sur la lpm en ce qui me concerne
je resterai totalement vigilant parce
que ça n'est pas que le diable est dans
les détails mais il ya toujours la
vocation de la part du ministère de
l'économie des finances le ministère des
comptes à bercy de continuer à rogner
les crédits de la défense c'est
inadmissible qu'il y ait toujours cette
volonté de la part de bercy pourquoi
cela l'état c'est lui qui est à
autorités cette chef des armées et
aujourd'hui même il vient de débloquer
500 millions d'euros dans le cadre de la
clause qui est prévu pour les
équipements militaires ça vous rassure
également je ne suis pas complètement
rassuré parce que je vais vous dire
pourquoi sur le papier il y à ce qu'il
faut mais nous savons dans le détail que
nous avons besoin d'opérations
exceptionnelles de ressources
exceptionnelles pour financer la loi de
programmation militaire
chacun sait notamment que sur
l'attribution des fréquences il y aura
d'ores et déjà un retard cela doit
procurer des ressources supplémentaires
pour financer la loi de programmation
militaire il y aura un retard comment se
fera la jonction maintenant je vais
aussi aller plus loin il faut aussi bien
veiller à ce que d'une façon ou d'une
autre même sournoise il n'y a pas de
remise en cause de cette lpm cette loi
de programmation militaire la loi de
programmation 1100 est brisée on nous le
dit elle est celle qui réalise et oui
mais sanctuariser eu une loi de
programmation militaire voter c'est bien
sanctuariser c'est bien exécuté
conformément à ce qu'il dit c'est qu'il
y aura de nouvelles réductions
d'effectifs s'il y en a eu il ya 158 lso
nicolas sarkozy la mémoire l'an passé où
également nous étions aussi dans un
modèle de forme à nos armées qui était
davantage adapté à la guerre froide il
fallait changer cela nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui à la fois de pouvoir nous
projeter comme on le fait notamment en
afrique nous avons aussi besoin de
continuer à moderniser notre armée est
cet enjeu pour l'armée
est aussi un enjeu de souveraineté
nationale la france n'est pas n'importe
quelle puissance elle un siège au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu la défense
est aussi un secteur dans lequel la
france baissent davantage que sa réalité
économique sa réalité démographique et
c'est aussi un poids en terme d'emplois
d'emplois non délocalisables vous
n'allez pas jusqu'à refuser par exemple
des fermetures de casernes il y en aura
forcément des régiments il y en a eu la
seule question liant nos rangs et encore
une fois il ya ce qui est prévu mais il
ya aussi est ce que le gouvernement a
l'intention ou pas de revenir sur le
format des régiments parce que ça aussi
c'est l'une des idées qui traînent votre
corps est impossible comme je
m'opposerai aussi à toute remise en
cause de la dissuasion nucléaire la
dissuasion nucléaire qui doit reposer
sur deux jambes une composante nous le
savons bien avec les sous marins
nucléaires est une composante avec les
forces aériennes stratégiques il faut
les deux et sur ce point même si je sais
que ça nous engagera en termes de
dépenses à l'avenir nous avons besoin de
garder cette forme les dissuasions
s'attend à ce que vous approuvez la
décision d'interdire en france des
manifestations pro-palestiniennes quand
elle exposait de nouveaux dérapages
antisémites 1 jusqu'à quasiment des
assauts contre des synagogues on l'a vu
à paris notamment donc je suis favorable
à l'internationa n'est pas nous protéger
contre l'importation de ce conflit
seulement ça n'est pas seulement protégé
contre toute attente antisémite mais
c'est aussi protéger les valeurs de la
république et il ya des points vous le
voyez bien je peux avoir des oppositions
frontales très déterminé avec le prénom
de la réplique on va le voir mais il y a
aussi des moments où on a le droit de
regarder ce qui est le plus important
c'est l'intérêt national et c'est
l'intérêt général mais surtout cela la
république peut être mise en danger les
valeurs dollar est aujourd'hui bien
évidemment la rue de l'errance de lutte
contre l'antisémitisme
est quelque chose d'essentiel on ne peut
pas tolérer la moindre atteinte à ses
principes et que le gouvernement
comprenne la réplique qui sont en charge
de ces questions aujourd'hui le fasse
c'est normal comme il est tout aussi
normal dans ces cas là que je fasse part
de la même position d'accord et sur la
position française cette fois ci
concernant ce conflit entre le hamas et
israël est ce que vous estimez que ce
qu'a annoncé
françois hollande est équilibré à vos
yeux ou ce qui me semble avant tout
important c'est la main tendue par
l'egypte d'accord qui a été accepté par
le gouvernement israélien et est
maintenant c'est clairement au hamas
d'accepter ça aussi c'est à dire un
cessez le feu immédiat mais je voudrais
aller plus loin je crois que chacun doit
bien comprendre que la solution de long
terme elle est politique et que toutes
les options sécuritaires seront des
options sécuritaires de court terme dans
cette région du monde où se joue pas
seulement l équilibre régional mais
beaucoup plus largement que cela il faut
absolument une solution politique de
l'ontt alors lors de son interview du 14
juillet le chef de l'état bien sûr
défendu ses réformes sur le plan
économique notamment il y a également
celle de l'organisation des territoires
la réforme territoriale qui est sur les
rails les députés ps ont présenté leurs
cartes de 13 régions avec le
rattachement de la picardie votre terre
d'élection au nord pas de calais est ce
que vous êtes là encore en accord avec
eux en accord avec mon ami gérald
darmanin député maire de tourcoing c'est
lui qui a rédigé l'amendement pour un
rattachement picardie nord pas de calais
après que les députés socialistes de
dire que c'est eux c'est pas le sujet
mais cette proposition cet amendement de
gérald darmanin j'y souscris je le
soutiens je suis pour ce rattachement
entre la picardie et le
nord-pas-de-calais yens beaucoup plus
forte cohérence qu'avec la champagne
ardenne et je pense que c'est la bonne
la bonne solution bien et compris par
exemple le département de l'oise on va
pas faire trop de jours à filmer nano
lamela long paille car très mal aux
oreilles 40 les régions est et de grâce
aussi regardons l'intérêt général quel
est l'intérêt général c'est que nous
changeons complètement l'organisation
territoriale en plus d'efficacité pour
plus dépit des économies nous dit on et
de visibilité des économies certainement
pas aussi importante que le gouvernement
avait bien voulu le dire la seule chose
c'est que cette réforme là de la carte
ça n'est que la première étape d'une
réforme d'ensemble de la carte
territoriale j'aurais préféré qu'il y
ait tout en même temps les compétences
la suppression des conseils généraux et
pas seulement 2020 tout de suite
d'accord suite était mieux maintenant
cela fait des années que je crois à
cette réforme territoriale vous la
réclame avec aujourd'hui de doha je la
propose en ce qui me concerne je ne vais
pas aujourd'hui
refuser cette réforme parce qu'elle est
proposée par françois hollande même si
la méthode honnêtement c'est du grand
n'importe quoi ou la vôtre est alors je
sais déjà aujourd'hui je ne voterai pas
contre cette réforme vous l'avez je ne
veux pas prendre cette réforme j'attends
de voir exactement les débats pour
savoir si je la vote ou si je m'abstiens
mais une chose est certaine je ne suis
pas un opposant
bête et méchant je ne suis pas un
opposant systématique je peux d'ores et
déjà vous dire que je ne voterai pas
contre cette réforme j'attends de voir
les débats parlementaires pour savoir si
je m'abstiens ou si je vote pour mais je
voudrais aller plus loin oui cette
réforme comportera d'autres étapes dans
ses autres étapes jeudi au gouvernement
et là ça fait partie de mes lignes
rouges il faut prôner le scrutin il faut
protéger les communes de france ce ne
sont pas les communes et notamment les
petites communes par la taille qui coûte
cher dans notre pays ce sont bien
souvent les grandes communes qui ont des
dépenses de fonctionnement trop
importante ou des dépenses de prestige
trop importante c'est l'intercommunalité
mal maîtrisée et c'était le doublon
département région donc je veux que l'on
protège à la fois les communes et aussi
la ruralité parce que plus vous avez des
intercommunalités qui grandissent plus
l'on parle de métropole l'on parle de
régions moins nombreuses et donc plus
vaste il faut absolument garder ce lien
entre la population le territoire et
l'onu voilà pourquoi je proposerai dans
les autres réformes qui viendront un
mode de scrutin qui ne soit pas la
proportionnelle la proportionnelle elle
éloigne les élus du territoire et de la
population puis la proportionnelle c'est
un truc pour les apparatchiks d'un truc
pour les partis politiques qui mènent
aux gens dont elle a évoqué c'est une
erreur parce que la proportionnelle
c'est justement l'instrument favori des
politiciens des politicards je suis pour
ma part pour que l'on revienne à un mode
de scrutin uninominal où les habitants
d'un territoire choisissent directement
le riz savent qui sait ils savent qui
sait et c'est ce qui permettra aussi
d'avoir en france c'est vrai à la fois
un fait urbain qui se développent un
fait régional mais de garder aussi la
ruralité pour que les les millions de
français qui habitent dans ces
régions-là se disent on existe toujours
et on commente et comment le chef de
l'état évoque donc la proportionnelle ou
bien le droit de vote des étrangers aux
élections locales vous lui prêtez donc
des arrière-pensées séjour des
politiques arbitres et des arrière
pensées politiques had évidente il était
formé à l'école de françois mitterrand
pour être sûr que le front national se
porte bien parce que c'est son intérêt
lui ce n'est pas l'intérêt de la france
qu'est ce qu'il fait il nous réussit le
il nourrit suscite le droit de vote des
étrangers je le dis clairement s'il est
dans les intentions du président de la
république d'aller vers le droit de vote
des étrangers aux élections municipales
je réclame un référendum parce que je
pense qu'un sujet aussi important il n'y
a que les français qui peuvent le
tranchées qu'on ne me parle pas de
réforme de la constitution devant le
congrès l'article 89 de la constitution
c'est aux français de se prononcer sur
un sujet comme celui-ci il faut dire que
je suis un partisan permanent du retour
vers les français du référendum mais sur
la question du droit de vote des
étrangers comme par hasard il agite à
nouveau maintenant c'est tout simplement
parce que il veut que le front national
soit le plus haut possible je le répète
c'est peut-être un intérêt de court
terme ce n'est pas l'intérêt de la
france alors françois hollande s'est
interrogé le 14 juillet lors de son
interview sur le quinquennat trop court
at il dit je sais pas si vous penser la
même chose et il alla il a lancé quelle
est la trace que je vais laisser qu'est
ce que j'ai fait est ce que vous pouvez
répondre à sa place la première des
choses c'est que vous le savez je plaide
pour cette idée depuis des années le
quinquennat était une fausse bonne idée
je suis pour ma part pour le septennat
le retour au septennat mais un septennat
non renouvelable
c'est à dire que celui qui serait élu
président de la république ne pouvant
pas se représenter n'aura pas en tête sa
réélection bien souvent même parmi les
plus courageux on se pose la question
pour une réforme et ce que je vois aller
jusqu'au bout et créent du
mécontentement ou chercher à faire
plaisir si vous voulez vraiment que
l'intérêt national redevienne la
priorité il faut débarrasser de la
république du souci de réélection
septennat nous renouveler nous parlait
déjà de votre programme de candidat
notamment l'ont dit pour quinquennat la
question qu'est ce que vous auriez dit à
la place de ou qu'est ce qu'il pourra
dire selon vous quelle est la trace que
je vais laisser qu'est ce que j'ai fait
pour m'en payer on peut déjà en parler
parce que j'entends ce que les trois
années qui restent n'effaceront pas les
deux premières années du quinquennat de
françois hollande il a été lu sur un
mensonge
sortez nicolas sarkozy et tout ira mieux
ils nous aident également il y avait un
double mensonge il n'y a pas de crise
mon arrivée va permettre à la france
d'être à nouveau florissante dont on a
un chômage qui est un niveau élevé comme
jamais et nous avons aujourd'hui des
français qui sont dans le doute le plus
complet et des français profondément
divisés par des réformes sociétales
comme le mariage pour tous le président
de la république aujourd'hui n'est plus
soutenu par personne regarder son
intervention hier vous avez dénombré
beaucoup de tweets de messages de
soutien de la part des socialistes dans
sa montre viennent sur 8 millions de
téléspectateurs comme d'habitude tous
les ans il y avait du monde sur 65
millions de français voyant que ses
impressions à la main pour être à la
fois entendu et surtout inspiré confirme
françois hollande n'inspire plus
confiance alors avant d'accueillir
guillaume daudin de la fp voyons cette
enquête de camilla campus à nos si vous
êtes d'accord xavier bertand comment à
l'elysée on imagine la fin du
quinquennat
une allocution sans annonce françois
hollande maintient le cap une constance
confortable même indispensable selon son
propre camp il faut de la constance en
politique et en politique économique on
peut pas changer de politique toutes les
semaines je suis pas en train de dire
que tout va bien madame la marquise on
en est loin on en est loin c'est une
bataille économique que nous livrons une
bataille que françois hollande livre
avec encore et toujours les mêmes armes
impulsée par le frémissement de sa cote
de popularité plus 2% il confirme et
assume sa politique une démonstration
d'autorité face aux députés frondeurs et
à l'ailé gauche du ps moi je continue à
penser que cette politique dans laquelle
le président semble allocution après
allocution s'enfermer est une politique
qui risque malheureusement de ne pas
avoir les résultats qu'elle cherche à
avoir sur le terrain du chômage on est
toujours devant la même faiblesse
politique à savoir 1 que cette politique
tue la croissance en tout cas la bride
et deuxièmement il n'y a pas
d'explication sur comment le fameux
pacte de responsabilité va être efficace
car beaucoup en doutent beaucoup
d'experts beaucoup d'économies
l'économie le nerf de la guerre
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage ne
se concrétise pas encore alors françois
hollande se fixe un nouvel objectif un
peu plus vague si vous m'interrogez
qu'elle est là si les gens que je
voudrais laisser que à la fin de mon
mandat en 2017 les français vivent mieux
que lorsque je suis arrivé aux
responsables des ça veut dire moins de
chômage et plus de pouvoir d'achat moins
d'impôts aussi un objectif relayé par
ses soutiens au parlement satisfait de
voir à présent appuyé qui dit que tout
n'a pas été essayées vis-à-vis du
chômage sur cette fameuse inversion de
copala cours et puis nous projeter nous
projeter à 2017 en disant qu'il souhaite
que les français en 2007 vise mieux
demain qu'aujourd'hui sans une
amélioration de la situation économique
d'ici à 2017 c'est la question des
primaires socialistes qui risque de se
poser voilà donc avec nos guillaume
daudin de la fp bonsoir guillaume en
question d'ailleurs je crois des
primaires socialistes un éventuel oui
vous disiez juste avant le reportage que
françois hollande lui inspirait plus
confiance ce week end jean yves le drian
a dit dans une interview que françois
hollande sera en situation d'être
candidats s'il le dit c'est peut-être
qu'il ya besoin de le dire je ne sais
pas ce que vous en pensez
si vous vous deviez parier sur les
candidatures 2010 sept ans qu'est ce que
vous pensez vous pensez que françois
hollande sera sera candidat je ne suis
pas pronostiqueur je ne suis pas
pronostiqueur socialisme et que le
ministre de la défense la veille du 14
juillet alors qu'il y a mille sujets à
traiter quand on est ministre de la
défense trouve le besoin de dire que son
ami président de la république actuel se
remplissant de se représenter c'est
vraiment qu'il ya danger et qu'il ya une
défiance généralisée y compris à gauche
mais elle s'explique 1 elle s'explique
parce que vous le voyez bien ça a été
très bien dit le reportage le premier
échec du président de la république
aujourd'hui c'est l'emploi il est en
situation d'échec total jamais le
chômage n'a été aussi élevé dans notre
pays et pourtant la crise n'a plus rien
à voir avec celle qu'on a connue en 2008
et en 2010 et ce ne sont pas des
statistiques ce sont aujourd'hui des
millions de français qui n'ont plus de
perspectives immédiates de retrouver un
emploi et d'autres qui se demandent de
quoi les lendemains seront faits
sur ce sujet il nous avait promis un
pacte de compétitivité responsable on ne
sait plus il ya tellement eu de pacte
les chefs d'entreprises se sont eux qui
recrutent qui créent de l'emploi ne voit
rien venir les syndicats ont la vue à la
conférence sociale tourner le dos du
gouvernement et du président de la
république et il ya des français qui
aujourd'hui sont soit dans l'abstention
soit dans la contestation parce qu'il ne
lui font plus confiance et ses
difficultés ça veut dire selon vous qui
aura peut-être une primaire à gauche
quelque chose si ce n'est pas mon sujet
la primaire à gauche jean alors on va
c'est le change et
frais mieux et il ferait mieux de se
soucier de l'intérêt de la france avant
de penser à la question de savoir s'ils
feront des premières balles à bon port
tout ça évidemment que l'on ait
l'ambition de vouloir être candidat
comme c'est mon cas c'est une chose mais
aujourd'hui pour les français ça n'est
pas le sujet et ils ont raison les
français donc il va y avoir une primaire
justement à l'ump on s'est creusé en
principe c'est pas encore elle aura lieu
elle aura lieu elle aura lieu j'en suis
persuadé pour deux raisons la première
c'est que c'est un choix qui a été fait
par l'ensemble de nos adhérents près de
cent mille adhérents qui ont décidé que
le choix du prochain candidat pour la
droite et le centre se ferait plutôt que
par les états-majors par l'ensemble des
électeurs de la droite et du centre ça
c'est la première des choses la deuxième
chose c'est que ça donnera à la fois une
dynamique pour la campagne
présidentielle mais au travers de ces
dynamiques qui aura le choix
passionnément d'un candidat mais d'une
ligne politique d'un projet et ça nous
permettra d'éviter comme ça a été le cas
à chaque fois qu'on est les grandes
déclarations les grandes promesses avant
l'élection et qu'on ait des grandes
déceptions les grandes trahisons après
l'élection nos électeurs ont peut-être
plus conscience que d'autres que la
france a besoin d'être réformé en
profondeur de façon efficace mais
surtout juste parce que la justice fait
partie de l'adn de la droite et du
centre et pour cela il n'y a que la
primaire qui n'aura l'occasion d'un vrai
débat d'idées alors le débat d'idées on
va beaucoup ont parlé notamment dans la
troisième partie de cette émission mais
avant il faut savoir si l'ump va pouvoir
garder sa crédibilité
il ya eu beaucoup de révélations ces
derniers temps luc chatel a proposé de
ce matin de d'essayer d'avancer sur la
l'exemplarité du parti
attention à la parité lors des
investitures il il a dit que ça pouvait
faire des économies la formule était
peut-être pas très heureuse parce que la
question c'est pas seulement pour faire
des économies c'est pas seulement qu'il
y à une loi mais il ya un phénomène
phénomène eu une marche en avant pour eu
une meilleure représentativité une plus
grande présence des femmes à tous les
postes de responsabilité
la loi est là qui vous aurez une
pénalité si vous ne le faites pas mais
on n'aurait pas dû attendre la loi pour
aller dans cette direction et on devrait
pas avoir peur des pénalités pour le
pour le faire ça c'est la première des
choses c'est le bon moment pour le faire
quand on a on a déjà tarder c'est
maintenant qu'il faut bien sûr mais en
attendant bon quand on a moins deux
sortants lors d'une élection c'est ce
qui va se passer en 2010 est pour les
justiciers vrai que c'est plus simple
aussi c'est plus enviable raison de le
dire que ça rien de tourner autour du
pot - vous avez deux sortants masculin
plus c'est facile d'imposer la parité
mais que la situation soit celle ci ou
pas il faut aller dans cette direction
vous savez des lois en la matière comme
celle-là la parité on peut les critiquer
mais il est vrai je le vois en tant que
maire de saint quentin nous devons
composer les listes à paris tessier pas
eu la loi on aurait fait comme
d'habitude un son il y aurait davantage
une homme parce que ça semblait plus
simple parce que alors que c'est une
erreur ce n'est pas plus simple mais ça
veut dire aussi que les femmes apportent
un regard différent sur la sur la
politique et qu'elles permettent aussi
de constituer un véritable
enrichissement pour les solutions pour
les réponses à apporter aux problèmes et
c'est pour ça qu'ils nous faut les ans
et direction à toutes les élections vous
souhaiter pour l'ump une nouvelle
formation politique vous avez dit une
nouveau nom peut-être une nouvelle
organisation nous les nouveaux partis un
nouveau parti un nouveau parti je pense
qu'il faut un électrochoc
je pense que compte tenu de toutes les
révélations qu'on a connus de la
défiance de la défiance qui s'est
installé il nous faut un nouveau parti
politique bien sûr à partir de ce que
l'ump avait de bon qu'est ce qu'il ya
devant l'ump nos adhérents nos élus de
terrain ceux qui sont pas déconnectés
ceux qui ne viennent pas complètement
fou quand il arrive à paris ceux qui ont
gardé le bon sens la fois de la province
nos valeurs elles sont toujours là et
elles comptent elles compteront pour la
france de demain la valeur du travail
l'ordre mais la famille l'eau mairie
toutes ces valeurs là sont là et puis
vous savez aussi ce qu'il ya sur le
terrain pour semble avoir perdu à paris
le besoin et le désir d'unité parce
qu'il n'y a que comme ça qu'on gagnera
c'est à partir de cela je pense qu'il
faut revoir l'ensemble de ce que été
l'ump parce que l'ump d'hier c'est
terminé c'est terminé mais il faut une
nouvelle organisation
totalement décentralisé où nous avons
parlé des primaires tout à l'heure où il
faut des primaires partout et pour tous
plus aucun poste de responsabilité plus
aucune candidature sans qu'il n'y ait eu
un vote des adhérents ça veut dire la
mort des parachutages et à mon avis a
pas grand monde qui va regretter les
parachutages et puis aussi sur le
fonctionnement financier
avoir une bonne gestion c'est possible
patrick devedjian avant moi et moi même
nous avons géré l'ump en faisant des
économies importantes 25 millions
d'euros économisés en trois ans patrick
devedjian est la preuve que c'est
possible et sur toutes les dépenses
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent qui
circule en politique des contrôles et la
transparence vous veut redonner
confiance c'est possible mais il faut un
électrochoc
il faut aller vers une nouvelle
formation politique mais attention pas
dans un an dans deux ans le congrès de
l'automne doit être un congrès
refondateur douze ans après la
constitution de l'ump il faut aller vers
une nouvelle formation politique sans
tarder la nouvelle formation politique
récupérerai le passé je n'ose pas dire
le passif de l'ump notamment sa dette
abyssale sa dette abyssale vous parlez
des 74 millions d'euros n'oublions pas
une chose
il ya un actif en face un immeuble ce
n'est pas parce que c'est moi qui ai
proposé l'acquisition mais l'ump n'est
pas à la rue parce qu'on est
propriétaire de cette image totalement
oui mais il existe il existe parce que
s'il n'était pas là on n'aurait plus
rien du tout on aurait que des liens sur
donc non seulement cet actif qui sera
ensuite valorisé à peu près à 40
millions d'euros face aux 74 millions
c'est plus la même somme et surtout ce
que nous avons su faire avec la streak
devedjian est encore bas oui mais vous
savez patrick devedjian en 2008 dix
millions d'euros d'économies mois en
2009 10 millions d'euros d'économies la
preuve que c'est possible de revenir
vers l'équilibré et je pense que notre
capacité à réduire l'endettement de
l'ump montrera si oui ou non nous sommes
capables de désendetter notre pays quand
nous reviendrons responsabilité c'est un
bon marqueur c'est un bon exemple
justement de le plan présenté par
l'audit financier parle de 55 millions
d'euros de dette après 2017 ça veut dire
quand en quelques années il va être
possible de rembourser 20 millions
d'euros mais qu'il y aura encore une
énorme dette en 2017 vous pensez que
c'est toujours possible de 2 est-ce que
ça pas grever la capacité de l'ump à
agir politiquement pendant ses années de
me dire si c'est possible mais il faut
gérer au plus près et excusez moi de le
redire un nouveau bien sûr que c'est
possible on l'a fait en 2008 en 2009 et
en 2010 donc là que celle ci n'était pas
aussi importante mais attendez on a
réussi on pas réduire le train de vie de
l'ump on a réussi à réduire les dépenses
de l'ump patrick devedjian et moi nous
avons su le faire donc c'est possible on
vous dit qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent qui
circule en politique beaucoup vous
n'avez jamais dit publiquement avoir été
choqué par certaines pratiques c'est pas
vous pouvez peut-être aujourd'hui le
dire écoutez en politique on n'est pas
obligé d'avoir recours aux consultations
aux appels d'offres quand on choisit un
prestataire moi je les fais notamment
quand il a fallu choisir les conventions
de l'ump mais ce qui est indispensable
incontournable
obligatoire pour les collectivités
locales dans une collectivité locale une
mairie plus de 15000 euros de dépenses
il faut justement une forme de
consultation ça n'existe pas en
politique de la même façon vous avez le
contrôle possible de la chambre
régionale des comptes dans une commune
savait pas forcément plaisir à tout le
monde mais c'est une pratique qui évite
les dérives ça n'existe pas en politique
dans une entreprise un comptable un
expert comptable commissaire aux comptes
voix des pratiques qui ne sont pas
convenables qui ne sont pas légales un
risque d'abus de biens sociaux il doit
alerter ça n'existait pas il ya des
modèles sont un contrôle un contrôle
d'opportunité interne il faut un
contrôle de régularité externe dans les
partis jeudi pour un parti c'est vrai
aussi pour les groupes parlementaires et
puis il faut de la transparence il
fallait publier les principales dépenses
ça évitera toute dérive et toute
tentation de dérive beaucoup d'argent
circule comme volée de saveurs qui a
forcément de l'enrichissement personnel
au passage qui a dit ça je vous pose la
question de choyer au sérieux on va
arrêter aussi de jeter l'opprobre sur
les mers des 36000 communes l'autre jour
j'ai un maire d'une commune alors là on
puisse elle m'avait on parle des parties
non mais attendez quand vous dites
enrichissement personnel on n'a pas le
droit de faire le lien comme ça sur
l'ensemble de la classe politique s'il
ya des gens qui se sont rendus coupables
d' enrichissement personnel cela ils
doivent payer et je suis même s'il ya eu
un enrichissement personnel pour que
l'on change dans la constitution un
principe et qu'on aille vers
l'inéligibilité à vie ça c'est la
première des choses mais j'ai notamment
des maires ruraux qui m'ont dit l'autre
jour
sur bertrand quand on pense que nous
ces quelques centaines d'euros par mois
que l'on touche pour la nati un intérêt
indemnités de maire que parfois même on
laisse dans le budget communal et quand
on voit les millions d'euros qui
circulent ou à paris mon dieu quel
décalage cette phrase résonne toujours
en moi et c'est vrai qu'on doit aussi
faire mille fois plus attention mais
qu'on doit aussi si certains se sont
rendus coupables d' enrichissement
personnel aller vers des mesures
drastiques inéligibilité à vie de façon
à ce que cela ne vienne plus pollué la
politique les dérives financières ont
été révélés par plusieurs plusieurs
journaux
et une mission d'inspection qui était
lancé l'ump pour retrouver qui à
l'origine a fait sa demande à votre
demande la demande aussi une qualité mis
en cause en indiquant que j'aurais fait
payer des vacances de fin d'année par
l'ump c'était totalement faux mais
c'était dans le but de me nuire j'ai dû
moi-même produire ma facture acquittée
par mes soins voyez un peu à quoi on en
est réduit donc le poème eva gina une
mission d'inspection non j'avais été
réduits mois à produire malgré tout la
mairie par mes chaussures mais derrière
simple moi je veux qu'on mette hors
d'état de nuire ceux qui ont pour
ambition de nuire à l'ump d'accord alors
cela même sans leur famille politique il
ya ceux là veulent justement avoir un un
trouble un désordre généralisé je pense
qu'il est beaucoup plus facile qu'on le
pense de savoir qui avait accès à ces
informations qui a pu s'en servir ou qui
a quitté l'ump en emportant des
documents qu'ils n'auraient jamais dû
quitter l'ump c'est l'enjeu de cette
enquête une petite idée j'ai encore une
fois et encore une fois cette enquête
solidement mener sérieusement menée elle
nous permettra d'aboutir un résultat
clair que l'on évite de polluer la vie
de l'ump parce qu'ils n'ont comme seul
dessein comme seul intérêt que de tuer
l'ump les partisans de jean françois
copé ont accusé dans les médias
justement le ceux de françois fillon
d'être à l'origine de ces boules puantes
il ya eu des jeux ne participe à aucun
concours de délation aucun j'ai demandé
une
ciot elle a été retenue tant mieux
qu'ils valent 1 quelle façon train qui
va l'amener vous demandez au triumvirat
et à luc chatel qu'ils auront tête je
pense que si elle est menée sérieusement
et rapidement on évitera à l'avenir
d'avoir deux de tels concours de
délation et de telles révélations qui
n'en sont pas je suis bien placé pour le
dire d'accord et on peut avoir des des
accusations telles personnes à donner
des informations à la presse vous pensez
que c'est ce qui marche bien aussi
précieux n'y a pas dix mille personnes
qui les détenaient ou qui avait axé
d'accord qu'il faut bien se le dise vous
avez vu debrecen
bon une autre question pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas candidat vous même à la
présidence de l'ump vous avez des
propositions pour le parti qui sont
construites vous avez vous les présentez
vous avez vous semblez savoir ce que
vous voulez pourquoi vous même y aller
pas j'aime bien jouer cartes sur table
j'ai dit que j'étais candidat à la
primaire de 2016 avec un projet projet
pour mon pays et et que je pense que des
personnes comme notamment françois
baroin sur tout à fait qualifié pour
incarner ce que doit être le nouveau
visage du président de mai mais avec des
critères précis le refus de la
cohabitation ici françois hollande
décidé d'aller dans cette voie de la
dissolution la deuxième chose c'est
l'organisation des primaires le refus de
toute alliance avec le parti de madame
le pen et je les dis aussi la mise en
place d'une nouvelle formation politique
si ces critères là sont remplies je
pense que je suis tout à fait prêt à
apporter mon soutien et c'est vrai que
j'aimerais bien que françois baroin ne
serait ce qu'en dit d'ailleurs par
ailleurs et il s'est porté candidat à la
présidence de l'association des maires
de france et on dire tous les cas
jacques pélissard qui est l'actuel
président de la mfd que ça n'est pas
compatible bon on verra ce que décidera
françois baroin merci beaucoup guillaume
daudin périssent jarno de public sénat
arrive maintenant nous allons évoquer
vos ambitions qui est vous amène à cette
attitude de rupture avec nicolas sarkozy
d'abord samia de sheer qui a tenté de
percer le mystère de votre préparation
c'était l'un des plus fidèles à nicolas
sarkozy on le surnommait le chouchou et
pourtant xavier bertrand kern
aujourd'hui la ligne la plus critique à
l'égard de l'ancien président une
rupture qui s'est amorcée bien avoir et
des fêtes de 2012 dans la relation
humaine forte qui lie à une kylie a
entre nicolas sarkozy et xavier bertrand
est un moment qu'elle sans doute dit
difficile pour xavier qu'est le moment
où jean françois copé prend la
présidence de l'ump s'il veut dire
secrétaire général alors que les alliés
n'avaient pas démérité je crois qu'il ya
eu une petite une petite cassure à ce
moment là quelques temps après la
défaite de nicolas sarkozy xavier
bertrand annonce sa candidature à la
primaire de l'ump il adopte une nouvelle
stratégie de communication entame un
régime et tente de changer son image et
une volonté de changer de ne pas être
celui qu'on croit si j'ose dire c'est
quelqu'un de l'aspérité xavier bertrand
alors qu'on le dit mourons et est
toujours consensuelle c'est quelqu'un de
caractère parfois même du mauvais
caractère alors qu'on a l'impression que
c'est le garçon sympathique les guignols
de l'info décrivez un peu en frais you
ses proches jurent qu'il jouera tout sur
la bataille des idées mais difficile
pour l'instant de savoir quel est son
projet entouré de quelques fidèles
parlementaire il s'appuie sur la
manufacture association de type boîte à
idées aux contours encore flous via une
alliance dans dance dans cette structure
entre des personnes qui ont appartenu à
ces différents cabinets entre des hommes
politiques ou entre des personnes de la
société civile qui connaît depuis un
certain temps qui ont des compétences
particulières issu du monde de
l'assurance xavier bertrand c'est un peu
l'anti énarque ironiquement surnommé
l'assureur militant dont on sait peu
mais fier souvent la technocratie à vis
à vis de la société civile un peu de
d'attitude
condescendante bien là nous avons un
responsable politique qui est courageux
déterminé on verra ce qu'il fera mais en
tout cas il faut pas le sous-estimer
c'est un haut potentiel de l'ump
pour l'instant seuls 3 % des
sympathisants le soutiennent dans la
course à la primaire mais d'ici 2016 les
multiples affaires de l'ump pourrait
bien rebattre les cartes
à monsieur 3% ça a porté chance à notre
métier 3%
on n'est pas sur la ligne de départ de
la primaire c'est loin c'est très loin
dans les enr idem des français que moi
je me prépare que que j'écoute beaucoup
je voyage beaucoup je construise un
projet c'est effectivement ma feuille de
route
mais pour l'instant j'ai bien conscience
que les français sont très loin de cela
ce sont eux qui ont raison non mais
c'est pas que c'est long le chemin à
parcourir vers une campagne
présidentielle ça passe souvent par une
envie de changer d'image de vous des
vérifier comment on fait quand on a été
comme vous ministre de raffarin de
villepin trois fois ministre enfin dans
les trois ministres de françois fillon
ça me donne déjà de l'expérience je suis
dans ma génération celui qui est
certainement conduit le plus de réforme
de l'assurance maladie et philippe
douste-blazy l'interdiction de fumer
dans les lieux publics la mise en place
du service minimum qui nous a évité les
semaines passent et la paralysie totale
du pays il ya eu des perturbations mais
plus la paralysie les régimes spéciaux
nombre de réformes sociales donc ça me
permet de savoir non seulement ce qu'il
est possible de faire et pourquoi aussi
les réformes n'ont pas été aussi loin
qu'il aurait fallu parce que bien
souvent en politique allez on fait
croire que la réforme est la plus
importante qui soit alors qu'en fin de
compte c'est celle qui répond le plus
aux compromis social alors qu'il faut
mieux qu'ils étaient présents enfin
mieux viser l'intérêt national l'intérêt
général et faire les réformes dont le
pays a besoin plus que les réformes que
les corps intermédiaires accès parce que
les corps intermédiaires ont leur
existence l'originalité mais il ne faut
pas qu'ils freinent notre pays dans le
besoin de réformes c'est ça qui est
important prenez notamment les les
retraites on est allé jusqu'à 62 ans
chacun sait qu'il aurait fallu qu'on
aille plus loin mais seulement en allant
plus loin y avait le risque qui est une
paralysie du pays c'est dans ces cas là
il faut pas hésiter à prendre à témoin
les français voilà pourquoi s'il ya un
risque de blocage ou si vous avez besoin
de la force nécessaire je crois au
référendum en début notamment de mandat
pour donner au prix de la république la
force nécessaire alors et faire un homme
ça la campagne présidentielle est une
élection présidentielle ça suffit la gt
le nom de réforme même durée combien de
référendum on croyait qu'en votant pour
françois hollande alors que certains
aient voté on repart pour quatre mois de
campagne sur un référendum je pense que
c'était important d'avoir un référendum
notamment sur la question du mariage
pour tous et si françois hollande ne l'a
pas fait c'est parce que bien sûr
c'était dans son programme mais beaucoup
de français n'ont pas voté en fonction
de ce sujet qui était si important pour
leur conception de la femme pour toutes
les grandes réformes pour faire un
référendum à pourvoir à tous les quatre
matins mais sur des sujets essentiels la
réforme des institutions
le septennat non renouvelables dont je
parlais tout à l'heure la réforme
territoriale au final au final je suis
convaincu qu hélas surtout avec un prix
à la république aussi faible aussi
fragiles politiquement la montagne de la
réforme territoriale finira par
accoucher d'une souris hélas s'il y
avait un référendum
aujourd'hui des passionnés des vous
l'utilisez la preuve je le regardais
référendum regarder ce que je vais tout
à l'heure sont passionnés regarder ce
qui se passe en mal de
moi excusez ma en alsace le oui au
référendum sur toute l'alsace l'a
emporté en faisant si je ne me trompe
pas cinquante sept pour cent sauf que
les règles étaient tellement compliqué
il fallait qu'il y ait un vote similaire
dans chacun des départements
voilà suffisant de votants voilà alors
en fait au final les alsaciens étaient
favorables mais les règles étaient trop
compliqué faut faire du simple au
politique vous êtes le seul à avoir fait
votre droit d'inventaire sur les harnais
sur les années sarkozy sur le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy votre
coming out finalement anti sarkozy
j'étais ministre je sais moi même je
sais moi même quels sont les points sur
lesquels nous nous avons fait ce qu'il
fallait et d'autres sur lesquels nous ne
sommes pas allés assez loin mais pour
que vous compreniez ni rien je lui ai
fait lors d'un déjeuner tout ce que je
dis aujourd'hui j'ai toujours ce
principe je lui ai dit avant et
directement mais pour moi ils vont
parler plus pour moi concrètement mais
attendez moi je suis pas ont posé la
question est-ce que je suis fâché ou pas
j'ai pas être fâché moi je suis opposant
à françois hollande bas l'ancien
président sans que vous vous tromper
d'adversaire comme ça en magnette en soi
ne certainement pas non c'est vous qui
me poser des questions depuis cinq
minutes non vous cherchez à m'opposer
moi je n'ai pas d'adversaire dans ma
famille politique au 15ème anniversaire
distinguer du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy le tandem et gt gt ministre non
mais attendez je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que le problème n'est pas
seulement nicolas sarkozy ça a été vrai
aussi avec jacques chirac et avec les
présidents précédents j'étais ministre
de jacques chirac avant d'être ministre
de nicolas sarkozy
je sais une chose c'est qu'il nous faut
dire la vérité aux français et leur dire
par exemple clairement que si l'intérêt
général sur la question des retraites
c'est de changer notre système de
retraite de garder la répartition mais
d'y ajouter une part d'epargne c'est
dire la vérité on ne freinera pas la
vérité aux français en leur faisant
croire qu'il faudra travailler jusqu'à
70 75 ans ce serait une erreur dire la
vérité je le revendique avoir le courage
de mener ces réformes je revendique
également mais pour que vous compreniez
bien il ya pour moi un avant et un après
européenne le soir des élections
européennes en voyant madame le pen
premier parti de france et même si vous
avez eu énormément d'abstention les
français ont quand même voulu que le
front national soit la première force
d'opposition est encore les révélations
sur l'affairé bygmalion sur le
financement de la présidentielle de 2012
c'était au lendemain des européennes si
ça avait été la veille je suis sûr hélas
que madame le pen aurait été à +30 % et
l'ump beaucoup plus bas si on n'a pas
compris ce soir lors si on n'a pas
compris que ce qui nous attendait si
nous ne réagissions pas c'était un
nouveau 21 avril alors là on n'a rien
compris à la france et aux français on a
rien compris et moi j'essaye à la fois
de comprendre et je veux réagir parce
que je pense que notre ambition
notamment de ce que doit être une
nouvelle formation politique à partir de
l'ump c'est pas de chercher à être
deuxièmes derrière madame le pen à la
présidentielle ce n'est pas d'être
qualifié pour le second tour c'est
d'arriver en tête et de ne pas penser
comme une fatalité que le front national
sera forcément au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle parce que c'est notre
incapacité à répondre
à droite voulait me dire quoi qui sera
candidat
il réfléchit y réfléchit alors à lui de
répondre il avait dit qu'il arrêtait son
engagement politique il peut incarner je
suis évidemment même un accord je me
suis analysé le porte-parole de qui que
ce soit parce que vous avez besoin de
nicolas ça qu'il m'a demandé de l'être
hélas que je pense qu'il le souhaitait
nicolas sarkozy ne va pas choisi pour me
faire plaisir à la traque aux ir
enregistre un gros décrochage dans les
derniers sondages comment est ce que
vous les analyser on la traite c'est
vous qui êtes journaliste politique ça
n'est pas mon cochon acteurs politiques
vous avez votre opinion bertrand non non
je suis pas commentateurs jeudi tout à
l'heure ni pronostiqueurs ni
commentateurs je pas envie de la
reconversion est 33% d'opinions
favorables quand même pour nicolas
sarkozy c'est un peu banon pour amorcer
un retour ne regardez pas les sondages
un mois comme ça il faut voir sur une
longue période mais la question
aujourd'hui vous savez les sondages
c'est aussi quelque chose qui peut être
trompeur ce qui est important en
politique ce sont vos idées et la
sincérité de celui qui porte ses idées
c'est ça le plus important et rien ne
remplacera jamais cela ni les sondages
ni même tous les moyens engagés dans les
campagnes politiques les campagnes
présentiel dans les idées la sincérité
et donc vous vous êtes déterminé qu est
ce qui vous laisse penser que votre
moment avoue est venu
c'est dans deux ans la primaire c'est
dans trois ans l'élection présidentielle
vous l'avez dit vous-même dans le
portrait qui était fait c'est vrai que
je ne viens pas du sérail je viens pas
de l'establishment mais souvent moqué
tout simple mais ce que je fais prise et
il ya eu beaucoup de mépris je n'ai
senti et ben ça ne crée chez moi aucun
esprit de revanche la revanche n'est pas
un bon moteur n'est pas une bonne
matière motivation en revanche je pense
que je suis peut être plus libre que
d'autres d'imaginer des solutions
nouvelles je pense par exemple pour
réussir à recréer de l'emploi avec le
retour de la croissance ça sera vrai au
niveau européen mais pour le faire au
niveau européen faudra un changement un
changement du statut de la banque
centrale européenne pour qu'elle ne
lutte pas seulement contre l'inflation
mais qu'elle favorise la croissance je
suis le seul à le dire parce que
peut-être que si je venais de
l'establishment je sais bien que
j'aurais pas le droit de dire ça rend
beaucoup jusqu'à un coma dans ma famille
politique parce que je n'ai pas été
formaté je ne viens pas du parcours type
ou d'une certaine façon vous disent
qu'il faut penser quand vous êtes élu
d'une ville comme saint quentin dans
l'aisne avait fait partie c'est tout
ma tâche politique quand même pas ce qui
m'a permis de faire plus de réformes que
d'autres parce que cette liberté j'ai
toujours porté en moi mais surtout
surtout depuis les élections européennes
je voulais dit je ne vois pas je ne vois
pas je ne veux pas voir arriver un
nouveau 21 avril
je ne resterai pas à me dire c'est pas
grave parce qu'en fin de compte on peut
gagner la présidentielle prochaine
droitiser son discours cette menace la
question n'est pas la droitisation la
question des honoraires le nom les
français ont des problèmes est ce que
les politiques ont des réponses à ces
problèmes sur l'emploi sur l'éducation
sur sécurité justice sur la protection
sociale voilà quels sont les angles du
projet les aspects du projet que je
porterai le moment venu mais il est vrai
qu'il ya des choses qui seront
foncièrement nouvelles comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure pour les retraites on ne
fera pas croire qu'en étant un peu plus
courageux que la fois précédente
donc ça suffira je voudrais aller plus
loin je dois aller plus loin dans la
gelée je les dis moi même repoussé là je
ne suffira pas vous le voyez bien quelle
retraite complémentaire sont en train de
s'éteindre et personne ne dit rien aux
rien dire vous croyez pas qu'il vaut
mieux avoir
système d'épargné en plus plutôt que de
laisser filer les retraites par
hypocrisie non je veux aujourd'hui bien
comprendre que la lucidité doit faire
partie allez des sentiments qui animent
les politiques la vérité et le courage
mais je veux aller plus loin juste pour
être très clair pour moi l'important
n'est pas seulement de gagner la
prochaine élection présidentielle parce
qu'il ya eu l'anti sarkozysme qui a
permis à françois hollande de l'emporter
certains se disent l'anti hollandisme va
suffire non ça peut suffire pour se
faire élire mais ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir la force le
soutien populaire pour mener les
réformes dont le pays a besoin et quand
on est élu contre quelqu'un quand on
n'est pas élu pour ses idées quand on
n'est pas élu pour son projet on ne peut
pas permettre à la france de rester ce
grand pays quel mérite de rester c'est
une course en solitaire certainement pas
vous avez vu qu'il y avait des
parlementaires qui me suivent beaucoup
d'élus locaux j'ai des milliers
d'adhérents de l'association la
manufacture j'ai beaucoup aussi
d'adhérents de l'ump qui se souviennent
combien j'étais à côté d'eux proche
d'eux quand j'étais à la tête de notre
famille politique maintenant je ne suis
pas seul si j'étais seul je ne pourrai
pas réussir ma chance et je ne suis pas
seul et on parlait d en parler
d'économie comment vous avez vu les
réformes le virage très libérale de
françois fillon ses références à
margaret thatcher la fin des 35 heures
la suppression de liesse pour que ce que
je veux dire avec ce type de programme
en angleterre certaines eaux en france
c'est plus compliqué la france c'est
plus compliqué la france parce que je
voulais dit tout à l'heure il s'agit pas
de porter les réformes plus loin que la
fois précédente je crois pour ma part
par exemple vous voulez aller sur
l'emploi faut changer la macroéconomie
au niveau européen au niveau national
baisser la fiscalité et donc baisser les
dépenses en premier vous voulez faire
reculer le chômage la baisse du coût du
travail ça ne suffit pas il faut
réformer le code du travail il faut
réformer le marché du travail sur tous
ces points mais vous comprenez bien de
la part de françois fillon qu'il est ces
idées moi je veux bien un débat d'ideye
françois fillon parce que le débat
d'idées sur le fond il est légitime et
vous rejoins au nez des différences sur
le faut c'est une chose non parce que
sur les retraites je veux être plus
complet que la seule question de l'âge
comme les dictateurs très bien y aura
effectivement cette proposition la
primaire permettra le débat d'idées bien
sûr voilà en 2016 et vous êtes bien
candidat on l'a compris merci à vous
merci merci merci ferrin c'est là une
dernière mission avant les vacances
d'été on se retrouve le 2 septembre noté
le tailleur perrine avec une série
spéciale de preuves par 3 consacrée aux
élections sénatoriales et le possible où
certains dit-on à l'ump bien sûr
basculement de cette assemblée à droite
bonsoir très bonne et et à très vite